We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. I got a very interesting and nice
of voicemail from Jordan Peterson with some
advice for my uh, uh, now, uh, earlier in
the week appearance on the Joe Rogan program.
Take, I'll take a listen to this warning from
Jordan Peterson.
Oh, Hi David.
This is Jordan B. Peterson calling in.
Just wanted to call because, so you heard
the exciting news that you might be on the
Joe Rogan podcast later this week.
So congratulations on that.
And uh, just wanted to call and also see a
to you.
Make sure you study up before you go on there
because I did it myself and, um, I didn't
have all my ideas and toy yearly coherence
in my head and realized after work when I
watched the video that I just said a whole
lot of Gobbledygook and Joe Rogan who seems
just like a stoner comedian type actually
got made a lot more sense than I did.
Okay.
So, uh, that's my advice and uh, again, congratulations.
So, okay, I'm going to take up by now.
Okay.
Bye.
Okay, so very good Jordan Peterson of course,
Canadian, not Irish.
And that started sounding a little bit Irish
in some places.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
I'll tell some behind the scenes stories from
my trip to La.
We'll talk about the Boston straight pride
parade, lovely city.
And uh, we will also talk about whether a
school officer should be jailed for child
neglect.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
It's a great time to support the shows that
you enjoy, that you think are important as
we have a growing ad apocalypse.
3.0 add boycotts in so many other things.
www.joinpacman.com it is very easy to become
a member.
It takes under one minute and you can save
40% if you want by using the coupon code.
This is 2020 that'll save you 40% off of the
membership